hey everybody how's it going my name's
mayuko and welcome back to my channel oh
highly anticipated video today because
we're going to talk about my stream
setup
i've been streaming for
[Music]
like a year ish now on twitch mainly
and i've gathered a lot of tools for
streaming and i wanted to talk about
which ones that i used today
i genuinely enjoy streaming most of the
time i stream like
co-working streams where we do pomodoro
timers together with some
chill lo-fi music playing in the
background and occasionally i'll also
stream playing games
i'm not very good at them but i enjoy
them
so a lot of the time i'll stream
something like ultimate goose game
sometimes i'll play valorant but oh my
goodness am i bad at that game but it's
fun sometimes
so we have fun on my twitch channel so
yeah streaming is just kind of a big
part of my life these days and i really
enjoy doing it
i know that some of y'all watching these
videos are from my stream so holla in
the comments if you are
today we're going to go over things like
computer my microphone setup what camera
that i use as well as
just some overview of the software that
i use and so we'll just dive right into
it let's get this thing going
before we get started thank you so much
to xteam for sponsoring today's video
xteam is a community of remote
developers that help communities scale
their development teams
so i know a lot of y'all are looking for
jobs right now and i think xteam could
be a very good opportunity for some of
you
when you join x team you gain access to
job offers working on long-term projects
for companies like riot games
fox coin base and you get 2 500
per year to use towards activities and
gear that help you stay energized and
always growing so this video is going to
be about my stream setup but extreme is
on the hunt for the perfect developer
desk
they asked me to view my current setup
and explain why it fits my developer
needs
so stick around to the end of the video
as you're giving away one of my favorite
desk items to upgrade yours
okay so the very first thing probably
the most important thing
actually definitely the most important
thing in streaming
is the computer so because most of the
time i'm streaming co-working sessions
i'm doing a ton of work on my mac and
given that the stuff that i do in my mac
tends to be pretty resource intensive
like editing or running xcode or
whatever
i tend to delegate the streaming part of
things to a completely different
computer
that computer is a windows yes it's a
windows
do i know how to use it well of course
not but i have one
this computer is actually a hand-me-down
from scott my husband because he always
builds his own pc for gaming
and he gave me this one because he
didn't need it anymore and wow is it
beefy and it's really great for
streaming
so it's a custom built pc but it's
running windows 7 and
the processor is the intel core i7
it's got 32 gigs of ram and
i don't i don't really know a whole lot
about how you specify
windows machines so there's a couple of
other specifications and so i'll leave
them right here for your convenience
but yeah it runs great i really like
using this as my streaming computer it
handles everything super smoothly and
really well
granted it does make my room hot because
it's a pc
but it's great for streaming oh and it
handles running a game
plus streaming just fine like i've never
had problems with
that and so it's perfect i like it the
next part of my streaming setup
is the camera so i know a lot of people
use a dslr
and set that up as a webcam but i don't
really have like a great
corner to put that in or rather i'm lazy
and i don't want to do that and so this
is actually another hand-me-down from
scott's setup this is the logitech brio
this is probably actually like the
beefiest webcam that you can get before
you actually use a dslr
but it's really nice the quality is
pretty good it connects straight into my
pc
super easily it's really easy to use
zero hassle
i will say that the auto focus on it a
little bit tends to be sort of wonky but
what camera isn't i just have it clipped
to the side of my desk and that's really
convenient because occasionally i'll
want to do like a top-down view for a
keyboard or something
and so i've been enjoying using this one
next we're going to talk about
my microphone and its stand so if you
watch the vlog linked right here then
you'll see that
i upgraded a lot of these next few parts
of my setup
and this is one of the things that i'm
so glad that i upgraded because it's
been so nice
so the microphone that i use is a short
sm7b like it is the
shore sm7b that a lot of artists and
streamers use
i love it i've used it for streaming as
well as recording some music
and it's just great y'all like it's just
so hassle free it picks up audio so
crisply
it doesn't pick up any like room sounds
or anything like that
super duper love it and granted i didn't
do like a ton
of research when looking for a mic i
knew that i just wanted to get
something that works well and i'm not
going to have any issues with
so i shelled out for a shore because i
was like it's gonna be a while before i
probably graduate from this one but this
is the one that a lot of
other youtubers podcasters streamers
recommend and so i got it and i have
zero regrets so the microphone itself is
mounted on the road psa1 pro studio arm
this is another one of those things
i didn't do like a whole lot of research
but it had good enough reviews it was at
a good price point
i really like road products in general
because i use a rode mic for
this stuff as well and so i tried it out
and i also
really like this one previously i had a
stand that would kind of creak and it
would like
pinch me often it was not fun
and so this one's just been great i
really like how freely i can
put the mic really anywhere i want to
around my desk
and it just sits there it's also got
some cable management which is really
nice because nobody wants cables
all over your computer and your desk
like that's not cool
ignore all of this cable messiness
because that's just for me to deal with
and so while we're on the topic of audio
next is my sound mixer and so the one
that i use is a presonus
studio 24c usbc audio interface
so i know a lot of people start with the
focusrite sound mixer but my husband
didn't actually have
great luck with that he said that there
was a lot of like random noise and stuff
that the thing itself creates and so i
was like well
if i know that that could happen let's
try this other one and so i bought the
presonus and honestly it's been great it
has two
inputs and it connects via usbc i can
change a couple of things on it but it's
a very simple
audio interface and because i'm not
doing anything super fancy with
lots of different inputs it's been
working great so yeah i really only use
like one of the inputs but occasionally
i'll also plug in my guitar because it's
an acoustic electric and play some music
on my twitch stream
so yeah i occasionally jam on my twitch
streams and that's fun because it's like
i can do what i want on my twitch
streams and
because my co-working sessions are
called muko's cafe
i often like to think of it as like it's
open mic night
with just one contestant me so
sometimes those are really fun to do and
the last like hardware-ish related thing
that's part of my stream setup is my
stream deck
and this is the elgato stream deck
everybody has this one this one is like
the de facto stream deck that you can
even like get at target or something
there's 15 keys on it that are
programmed to various applications that
i use that i'll get into in a bit
um but it's just been really convenient
to be able to toggle different things at
the push of a button
and the stream deck itself supports a
lot of different applications and so
i had some fun kind of playing around
with it you can even create like
multiple interfaces of it to do
different things
but it's just been super convenient i
think instead of needing to like
click and drag and switch to different
applications and stuff
it kind of feels like i have like my own
mission control and so that just adds
like a fun dimension to streaming but
yeah the stream deck is not something
that like i absolutely
needed for the stream setup uh it's just
a very like nice to have in fact my
moderators got this for me for like my
one year anniversary and
it has made my life easier but i
wouldn't say that this is like a
you need to have this in order to start
streaming obviously
so next up we're going to talk about
software so for the streaming part of it
i use streamlabs obs streamlabs has been
pretty easy to use in creating different
scenes and making sure that all of my
audio and video is working as well and
being able to see the chat and whatnot
i wouldn't be able to tell you the
differences between all of the obs
platforms out there but streamlabs has
been just
easy to use and so i've been using that
one in conjunction with stream labs i
also use nightbot which is a bop that
can kind of do like a lot of different
things for you
it has its own auto moderation stuff in
addition to what is done on twitch
as well as being able to add commands
that you use often and
song requests you can do giveaways it's
kind of just like an all-in-one that i
also use with my streaming stuff
and then for sound mixing i use voice
meter potato sound mixing
and all of like managing audio inputs
and outputs
is like calculus to me in my brain
so i have like a diagram that i use with
myself and scott
whenever we need to debug audio issues
and oh my gosh
my brain feels like it does backflips to
understand it all
but it's one of those things where you
set it up once and you hopefully never
have to touch it again
but voicemeeter potato i feel like
otherwise makes all of that pretty easy
to deal with
also voicemeeter potato allows you to
add reverb to your voice so
again important for the jam sessions so
again thank you so much to xt for
sponsoring today's video
like i said i've done a ton of desk
related videos before
and so i'll link them in the description
box down below for you to check them out
as far as my current setup goes i'm kind
of changing it around right now i'll
make a full video once it's settled down
a little bit
but one of the things that i'm really
enjoying that's kind of a newer addition
to my desk setup
is my grovemade desk mac i've actually
been eyeing this one for a while because
i thought the color was really nice and
it would fit well with my desk color
the wool seemed really nice and i wanted
something that kind of could act as a
mouse pad
and just a landing station for my
keyboard and mouse
so when i got this sent from grovemade i
was so happy because it really lived up
to my expectations
i just think it works really well on my
desk and i feel like it brought
everything together really nicely
x-team wants to help upgrade your setup
and so they're giving away one of these
to you all
so to participate in the contest you
just need to write a comment with a
hashtag
x team life they'll choose a random
winner from all the video comments and
the contest will run for a week
i really hope that you watching this
right now wins it and so good luck
thank you so much again to x team so
that's it thank you so much for watching
today's video i hope you enjoyed it
and i also hope that you come hang out
with me on twitch.tv
hello moyuco every once in a while we
have a very kind community of people who
co-work together it's very like positive
and wholesome
part of the internet that i'm very proud
to have created and helped build so
come hang with us tomato titans if you
like this video and you want to see
other kind of like tool
desk setup related videos that i haven't
covered before then let me know in the
comments down below and as always don't
forget to subscribe to this channel to
get updates about new videos that i
create all the time
and i will see you next time bye